still smoking the chemical fire on board
the stricken vessel
is now out but too late to avert an
unfolding environmental disaster
the nitric acid which was being
transported on the express pearl
is thought to have burnt off but with
the cargo ship
slowly sinking a last glimpse of some of
its
1500 containers it had been carrying
plastic pellets used to make things like
plastic bags millions of the pellets
have washed up on sri lanka's pristine
beaches
presenting environmentalists with a
plastic time bomb
already they're documenting the feared
impact on marine life
like this dead turtle it's pretty sad to
see
i visited one of the beaches uh today
the one that's
sort of directly opposite where this
ship caught fire
where all like a bulk of the pellets
have been
uh collecting and it's not a pretty
sight it used to be this beautiful
tropical beach with coconut trees along
the side
very idyllic and today when i went there
i was i was very heartbroken to see
um piles of plastic pellets everywhere
efforts to tow the cargo ship further
out to sea to dilute the environmental
damage it's
causing have failed it is just nine
nautical miles from the port of colombo
fishermen who've been ordered to stay in
port are angry that their livelihoods
hang in the balance
the ship has dealt a fatal blow to our
lives we can't go to the sea which means
we can't make a living
the indian and sri lankan navies have
been working together for several weeks
to try to stop the ship from sinking
it's not yet clear whether a major oil
spill has been averted
but it's feared the spillage of plastic
pellets could get
carried to beaches as far away as
indonesia
a distance of 4 000 kilometers
lisa holland sky news